i wanted to mention the real cool
benefit of
rebound exercise
nasa has done quite a bit of research on
rebounding
and i'm going to put some links down
below but it's actually quite
fascinating
that they're doing research on
rebounding
because what they found is when you're
in space without gravity
you start losing your bone tissue
and your muscle tissue so they're trying
to come up with ways to
counter that but rebounding exercise is
jumping on a trampoline
now if you're going to do rebounding and
you're a little bit older i would always
recommend
doing it with some type of support
structure so you can hold yourself
because
you don't want to be jumping on this
trampoline and jumping off and
you know falling or injuring yourself
but there's quite a few benefits to
rebounding exercise it's convenient
it improves your mobility your posture
your balance your gait it improves the
fear of falling it can even reduce your
risk of osteoporosis
but i think the biggest benefit has to
do with this
right here stimulating the lymphatic
system
so let me make this very very simple
what is the lymphatic system
you have the blood vessels throughout
the body the vascular system right
and they go from large vessels to
smaller vessels
to eventually to tiny little blood
vessels called
capillaries in the tissue now in that
same tissue next to the capillaries
you have the beginning of the lymphatic
system some of the plasma in the blood
leaks out into the tissues and it goes
right into the lymphatic system
so the fluid in the lymphatic system
called lymph
is made up of plasma and several other
things which i don't want to get into at
this point
and then the lymph system travels
through the body and then eventually
dumps back
into the vascular system the venous part
of the vascular system so it's this
whole
continual loop so one function of your
lymphatic system is to act as a
backup for your vascular system so if
there's too much blood for example
the lymph system can handle that
overflow
but the thing you need to know about
your lymphatic system
is it doesn't have a pump
like the vascular system does so it
needs
movement or else there's no pump
the lymph becomes stagnant or congested
the two big purposes of the lymphatic
system
are number one to support the immune
system because you have all these lymph
nodes
and you have all these t cells and b
cells that help to
capture and consolidate pathogens that
have invaded the system
and deal with them kill them and just
disregard them
as well as to help recycle old
red blood cells and damage red blood
cells and
recycle them that's what the spleen does
the spleen is a very
large lymphatic node and the other
function of the lymphatic system that a
lot of people
are unaware of is that it helps to
transport
fat to the body so when you eat
dietary fat and it goes into your
intestines
it goes directly into the lymphatic
system
not into your blood vessels fat in water
do not
mix so the body has to package this fat
in a way that can be transported easily
through the system
so one way that it packages the fat is
through something called a
kylo micron the word kylo means
juice and microns mean small particles
so a kylomicron is very simply
the grocery bag that carries the fat
to the various parts of the body for
both energy and
as a precursor or material to build
hormones especially adrenal hormones to
counter stress
all of the hormones in the gonads the
testosterone
estrogen progesterone are made from
fat and cholesterol the cellular
membranes
need fat the nervous system the brain
needs fat bile comes from cholesterol
vitamin d
comes from cholesterol so in other words
this fat is very very important
to supporting body tissue as well as
giving you energy
and one very common thing that i hear
over and over and over when people start
doing rebounding exercise
is their energy goes straight up and
vertical i think it has a lot to do
with the fat being more activated in the
lymphatic system
so the biggest benefit of rebounding
exercise has to do with supporting the
immune system
and to help the transportation of fat
through the chylomicrons
now as a little side note since we're on
the topic of chylomicrons
i want to just help you understand this
a little bit better when you get a
cholesterol
test you usually get your total
cholesterol you get ldl
hdl right now let's take a look at this
a little bit deeper
when someone talks about ldl or hdl
they're not talking about cholesterol
they're talking about the carrier bag
okay the the grocery bag that's carrying
the fat through the body and so we have
different
densities of these bags different sizes
and different densities
so when we're going from a kylo micron
that's the largest bag
it's also called the ultra low density
lipoprotein
and they're calling it ultra low because
it's basically
filled with fat and
very little protein and if we look at
the relationship between
this all the way down to hdl you can see
this is a lot smaller this is the most
dense
this is the least dense okay so this has
the least amount of fat the most protein
this has the most amount of fat and the
least amount of protein
so when we go this direction more dense
more protein less lipids
why because these are carrier bags that
are going to be dumping off
fat into various parts of your body
so we go from a cola micron which is an
ultra low
dense lipoprotein to a vldl
that means very low density lipoprotein
and then there's a little extra step
right here called
intermediate density lipoprotein and
eventually we get to the
low density lipoprotein and most people
think this is the bad one but there's
actually
two types of ldl there's one that's more
pathogenic
and one that is non-pathogenic if you're
interested i put some links down below
about that
and then we get the hdl which is a
carrier bag
that takes the cholesterol from the body
tissue and brings it
back into the liver these other ones are
going to the liver
anyway sorry i got sidetracked there for
a minute the main thing you need to know
about rebounding is it's
really good for your lymphatic system
especially if you have lymphedema
all right thanks for watching before you
go
if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin
keto or you're on keto and you need a
debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help